unarmed and undergoing flight trials for
now but this new drone could become a
key weapon against terrorist threats in
afghanistan
a sign of how weapons to fight terrorism
have advanced since the september 11
attacks
but so too has the threat
i think it is more global
i think the threat is
not as
focused at the moment but we certainly
see a whole group of people who have the
knowledge of doing terrorist attacks and
we see people trying to communicate with
each other to do that in the future so i
don't think it's greater in one sense
but i think the reservoir of people who
might cross that line into violence is
probably greater than it was
it's why military chiefs value the
ability to strike from the air at a
distance
something that just became all the more
important after british and u.s ground
troops left afghanistan
well it's not due to be operational for
another three years
this drone when laden with cameras and
weapons is going to be able to fly up to
1200 miles to hit a target that's double
the range of the current unmanned
aircraft it means the government will
have more options when dealing with
terrorist threats
afghanistan's new taliban rulers have
pledged to stop the country again
becoming a launch pad for terrorism
but no one forgets that's exactly what
they allowed to happen in the run-up to
9 11.
a reason perhaps for the cia director
pictured on the left to visit military
chiefs in next door pakistan a vital
regional player
the early signs from the ground though
aren't great
here the empty cells of bagram prison
north of kabul where the u.s had kept
some of their highest value al qaeda and
islamic state targets
the face of terrorism also changing it's
much harder to define who is alpine or
what are they because
survival mechanisms have meant that
they've blended
with political groups with tribal
militias with other interest groups
so it's quite hard to figure out who the
enemy is and to know where to where to
draw the line it all underlines the
limitations of relying on machines to
counter this ever evolving threat
debra haynes sky news